[موسيقى]
قد لا يبدو هذا الهلام الراسخ الذي لا طعم له
كثيرًا
ولكنه لا يحتوي على سعرات حرارية ويستغرق الأمر
سنوات لصنع
يسمى kanyaku ، وقد تم إنشاؤه من
جذر نبات خاص
وقد تم صنعه بنفس الطريقة تقريبًا
لآلاف
السنين وهذا الجيل الرابع  يضيف المزارع
مكوّنًا خاصًا واحدًا
[الموسيقى]
يستخدم غي كونياكو لتحسين عدد
من الأطباق
[الموسيقى]
[الموسيقى
] ويبدأ إنشاء العلاج الخالي من السعرات الحرارية
بتنمية
وزراعة المكون الرئيسي
konjac
المعروف باسم konnyaku  البطاطس
على الرغم من
أنها ليست بطاطس في كل هذه
الجذور الرقيقة ،
تقضي الشتاء في التخزين لحمايتها
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
بعد شتاء من الحفلات الخاصة ،
يتم إعادة زراعة الجذور في فصل
الربيع  مرة أخرى في الخريف واستعادتها
قبل أن تُزرع مرة أخرى
، قد يستغرق الأمر ما يصل إلى ثلاث سنوات من النمو
حتى تصبح النباتات جاهزة
للمعالجة
، ويتم غسلها وتقشيرها وخلطها
بالماء وتحتاجها
قبل أن يتم سكبها في طبق مربع
لإعداد
[الموسيقى]
ولكن النتيجة النهائية تستحق العناء
الآن بالنسبة
لي